(audience clapping)
- So Ken and I both have shows
in which listening to the
music is very important.
While Jurnee stars in a rad new movie,
based on comic book characters.
So we thought we'd combine the two worlds
in a game called name that toon!
(audience cheering)
(upbeat bubbly music)
(laughing)
Jessie your job is awesome!
In front of us we each have
a list of cartoon characters.
We will take turns doing
impressions of those toons
without saying the
names of the characters.
So you don't necessarily
have to sing or anything,
you just have to act, you have to tell us,
you know without saying it.
- Act it out.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- The goal is, you
probably understood that,
I was explaining it for me.
(audience laughing)
The goal is to get the other two people
to guess the toon you're impersonating.
I'm nailing this Ken.
(laughing)
- Toon is killing it.
(everyone talking)
- We'll be right back
with Captain obvious.
(group laughing)
- It's fine!
I'm just spelling it out for
you like a Kindergarten teacher
Whoever hits the button and
guesses the correct character
- WE GET IT!
- GET THE POINT!
- GET TO THE POINT ALREADY!
- IF YOU'RE WRONG THE
OTHER PERSON CAN STEAL!
Okay whoever has the least points though.
Hey whoever has the least points
whoever the loser is has to,
you're forced to read
us to commercial break
in the cartoon character
voice of your choice.
- Okay
- It won't be me so y'all get ready.
- I'm amazing at games guys.
All right you ready?
- Yes.
- Okay, here we go. Oh that's upside down.
(laughing)
- Man
- I am drunk. It's fine!
- You were drinking some coquito's.
- I was drinking
coquito's. Thank you Rosie!
Okay this one, okay. Oh wait am I ready?
He has a side kick and he,
oh God how does he sound?
(Yogi bear impersonation)
Oh I dunno I'm hanging out by the tree
and I like my some honey and I'm
(buzzer ding)
- YOGI BEAR!
- YES!
- Thank you! I didn't know how to do that.
I felt confident and
then got shy about it.
- [Jurnee] You got really
insecure, it's okay.
- I thought that was
cartoon John Travolta.
I didn't know, I was trying to think.
- Okay Ken it's your turn.
(group laughing)
I'm ready.
- This one, okay.
(Homer Simpson Impersonation)
Doh!
(buzzer bell)
- Oh Homer Simpson!
(bell ding)
Yes!
(audience applauding)
- [Jurnee] Oh! That was good!
- Yeah! Jurnee you're up!
- Okay, yep.
(Bugs Bunny impersonation)
(crunching)
- Aye, what's up Doc?
(buzzer bell)
- Oh Bugs Bunny!
(bell ding)
- Yes.
- Yes!
- Really? Was that Bugs Bunny?
- LISTEN KID! You're not
gonna judge my Bugs Bunny!
- Really? No I
- It was the carrot. It
was the carrot right?
- It was the carrot and I said,
'What's up Doc?'! Is that not Bugs Bunny?
(audience laughing)
- You're thinking of Elmer Fudd.
- Oh no
- You're thinking of.
Are you thinking of?
- Jennifer Aniston?
- WHAT?!
(everyone laughing)
What? What?! (laughing)
- I'm good at voices.
- I'm good. What's up Doc?!
- This is
- Yep. A for effort!
- We didn't say really
hot person from Friends!
- Oh okay!
- Okay, final round! I got
this one. Okay. I think.
(Tasmanian Devil impersonation)
(laughing)
- WHAT?!
- Y'all don't know who it is?
(buzzer bell)
- I know who it is.
Blake Shelton! I know who it is.
(blaring buzzer)
(audience laughing)
WHAT?! I'm trying! Why
are you laughing at me?
- Wait is that not what it.
I feel like he does this.
Look. See! And he does this
thing like really fast.
- Classic Shelton. That's what I'm saying.
(Tasmanian Devil impersonation)
- Oh Tasmanian Devil! Yes!
- That's not Tasmanian Devil!
I'm gonna call my lawyers.
- Isn't it? I don't, it might not be.
(laughing)
Okay Ken, it's your turn.
- Oh sorry.
- And since you're so amazing at it!
(laughing)
- [Jurnee] Right.
- Oh Okay. (laughing) Oh my God.
(Pop-Eye impersonation)
(buzzer bell)
- Oh Spinach! Oh Pop-Eye.
(bell ding)
- POP-EYE!
That was good!
- That was the worst Pop-Eye!
- No you did the thing and the muscles!
That was good. That was good.
Don't doubt yourself. You're great!
Jurnee your turn.
- He lives under water and
you also use this thing
to clean your kitchen counter.
- Oh! SpongeBob Squarepants!
- Yes!
That was awesome! You're good!
- Okay and with the
lowest number of points,
I'm sorry Jennifer Aniston, but it's you!
(laughing)
- I demand a re- no that's
accurate! Okay yeah!
- No Ken! You get to
take us to break loser!
- Okay, okay.
- In you're best character
voice. Don't do Cartman.
- Should I do the Pop-Eye.
- Yeah!
(laughing)
(inaudible) some facts
and go see Birds of Prey
in theaters now. We'll
be right back (inaudible)
- WHAT?!
(audience cheering)
- Don't miss it!
(drums)